[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedrige Sirin ihnen allen guten Abend
Norbert Lehmann im Sport unter anderem
mit einer neuen dfb-personalamt auch von
mir und wir können sagen es war ein
intensiver Tag für die deutsche
Sicherheitspolitik hier sind unsere
Themen
Schnellstart Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius legt amtsalt ab und trifft
gleich danach us-kollege Austin die
Ungeduld in der panzerfrage wächst
Betten vor dem Reichstag long koved
Betroffene protestieren für die
Anerkennung der Langzeitfolgen von
corona-infektionen und Impfungen
und neuer Chef für die
Nationalmannschaft Rudi Völler soll als
DFB-Sportdirektor bis zur Heim 2024 für
neuen Schwung sorgen
[Musik]
Boris Pistorius ist Deutschlands neuer
Verteidigungsminister heute wurde er
vereidigt und das in einer Zeit in der
die Frage nach deutschen
kampfpanzerlieferungen immer drängender
wird das vertiefen wir gleich erst der
Blick zum neuen Verteidigungsminister
der quasi von 0 auf 100 ins Amt
geschleudert wird nach seiner
Vereidigung empfing Pistorius den
us-amtskollegen Austin zur Vorbereitung
der morgigen Konferenz in Ramstein mehr
von ihnen Trumps
freundschaftlich ein bisschen wohl auch
erleichtert begrüßt die zurückgetretene
Christine Lamprecht ihren Nachfolger am
Bendlerblock seinem neuen Amtssitz vor
dem Hintergrund des Angriffskrieges auf
die Ukraine will Boris Pistorius die
Bundeswehr stark machen es ging um
Abschreckung und Einsatzfähigkeit
[Musik]
Deutschland ist nicht Kriegspartei
trotzdem sind wir von diesem Krieg
betroffen
die Bedeutung der höheren Sicherheit ist
eine andere als noch vor einem Jahr er
verspricht für Truppe und Mitarbeiter im
Ministerium da zu sein sucht aber auch
deren Unterstützung ich brauche jeden
einzelnen ich brauche die Unterstützung
aller und ich werde sie auch einfordern
im Morgengrauen bereits Termin im
Schloss Bellevue Pistorius erhält von
Bundespräsidenten seine
Ernennungsurkunde eine Amtsübergabe vor
düsterer Weltpolitik
sie übernehmen das Ministeramt in einer
bedrohungs- und Gefährdungslage die
Deutschland lange nicht mehr kannte
nächster Stopp Bundestag die
entscheidenden Worte des Tages ich
schwöre dass ich meine Kraft nach
Vereidigung und Applaus von allen
Fraktionen muss er schon weiter sein
erster internationaler Gast wartet US
Verteidigungsminister Lloyd Austin
Panzerlieferungen erwähnen sie auf dem
Podium nicht aber hinter verschlossenen
Türen ist es das Thema Washington drängt
Berlin zögert vor den Kameras nur
freundliche Worte ich möchte der
deutschen Regierung für all das danken
was sie getan hat um die ukrainische
Verteidigung zu stärken ihre Beiträge zu
Gerät und Ausbildung für ukrainische
Kämpfer waren unbezahlbar
auch gerade jetzt in diesen Zeiten
stehen die Bundesrepublik Deutschland
und die Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika
dabei Schulter an Schulter morgen beim
Treffen der westlichen Verbündeten in
Ramstein wird Pistorius Farbe bekennen
müssen liefert Deutschland Kampfpanzer
an die Ukraine oder nicht auch sein
zweiter Tag im Amt wird ein harter
werden
eben weil es in Ramstein auch um die
deutsche Position geht der Druck auf
Deutschland ist jedenfalls enorm Ukraine
ist Präsident kritisiert Berlins
zögerliche Haltung als Leopard
panzerhersteller Genehmigungen zu
erteilen bzw selbst zu liefern immer
mehr internationale Partner wollen das
Warten aber bislang vergeblich auf
grünes Licht von Kanzler Scholz der wäre
angeblich bereit aber nur wenn auch die
USA Kampfpanzer schicken Nicole
Dieckmann
Zerstörung Leid und Tod hier in nepro in
der Ukraine oder auch hier in bachmut in
der Ukraine der Krieg tobt und die
Debatte darum endlich Kampfpanzer zu
liefern im Zentrum Deutschland und
verhohlene Kritik am Kanzler vom
ukrainischen Präsidenten ja zu sagen ich
liefere dann Panzer wenn andere auch
Panzer liefert und ich bin mächtig in
Europa und werde dann helfen wenn jemand
von außerhalb Europas hilft ich glaube
nicht dass das eine perfekte Strategie
ist
selensky spielt damit auf Medienberichte
Anwohner der Kanzler auf die
Entscheidung der USA wartet Kampfpanzer
zu liefern erst dann werde Scholz grünes
Licht für den Leopard 2 Panzer geben 14
europäische Staaten haben den Leopard 2
darunter Polen was Polen nicht mehr hat
Geduld die Zustimmung ist jetzt
zweitrangig wir werden entweder schnell
eine Einigung erzählen oder wir werden
selbst das Richtige tun rote Polens
Regierungschef gestern mit einem
Alleingang im Gespräch mit dem ZDF liegt
sein Vize aus Minister heute Nacht
wenn die Deutschen nicht mitziehen
beweisen sie dass sie kein Mandat haben
um über die Zukunft der EU zu
entscheiden
auch im Bundestag heute Vormittag der
Leopard 2 im Fokus CDU und CSU erhöhen
den Druck beantragen eine Abstimmung die
Weigerung des Bundeskanzlers und die
nicht Lieferung Deutschlands ist ein
Alleingang der falsch ist der
unverantwortlich ist und der die Ukraine
in einer entscheidenden Situation im
Stich lässt
Stempel weiterhin auf der Suche nach
einer gemeinsamen Position Grüne und FDP
klar für die Lieferung die SPD jedoch
nach wie vor skeptisch
jeder für falsch und ein gewisses
Skepsis gegenüber der Politik die
ausschließlich der militärischen Logik
folgt ist angesichts unserer Geschichte
nur angebracht die Abstimmung über die
Lieferung des Leopard 2 hat die Ampel
heute verhindert so einfach wird es für
Deutschland morgen hier in Ramstein beim
Treffen mit den westlichen Verbündeten
aber ganz sicher nicht
holen wir Theo call in Berlin in die
Sendung Theo in Sachen
kampfpanzerlieferungen wird morgen in
Ramstein erwartet dass sich Deutschland
bewegt wird Scholz dem Druck standhalten
naja also Druck standzuhalten das zählt
ja eigentlich zu den von Olaf Scholz
selbst zelebrierten Eigenschaften
diesmal dürfte es aber wieder
erstrebenswert noch sinnvoll sein der
Kanzler hat sich erneut wie schon bei
den flugabwehrpanzern Gepard in eine
Ecke gepinsel der wolle ja nur dann
Leopard Panzer liefern oder von anderen
liefern lassen wenn die USA ihrerseits
schwere Kampfpanzer liefern das aber
haben die USA ja schon abgelehnt
vorstellbar ist dass Deutschland morgen
beim Rammstein treffen zumindest die
Leopard Lieferung durch andere Länder
beispielsweise Polen genehmigt das wäre
dann allerdings ein weiterer Schritt in
einer ganzen Serie von Zugeständnissen
bei denen die Bundesregierung jedes Mal
wie eine getriebene wirkt und erst auf
äußeren Druck reagiert und das obwohl
Deutschland zu den größten helferstaaten
der Ukraine zählt also eigentlich eine
Erfolgsgeschichte erzählen könnte the
bislang bleibt Deutschland aber
vorsichtig wird da gerade
internationaler Zusammenhalt verspielt
naja zumindest wird der Zusammenhalt
hart auf die Probe gestellt und ganz
nebenbei gilt das auch für das
internationale Ansehen Deutschlands in
einerseits verweist Berlin und die
SPD-Führung ja auf die deutsche
Führungsrolle in Europa und andererseits
bleibt die militärische Linie sehr
zögerlich Berlin bleibt ja gerne hinter
dem breiten Rücken der Amerikaner im
Kanzleramt und auch in einem nicht
unerheblichen Teil der Bevölkerung wird
diese Zögerlichkeit oder
Risikovermeidung aber ja umgekehrt
positiv bewertet und gleichgesetzt mit
Vorsicht Olaf Scholz betont immer wieder
dass er alles daran setze einen NATO
Russland Konflikt verhindern zu wollen
und nicht zu vergessen für kein anderes
Land ist der politische und
gesellschaftliche Weg zur Zeiten wenn du
so weit wie für Deutschland und das geht
ganz besonders für die SPD auch das
spiegelt sich natürlich in den
militärischen Entscheidungen des
Kanzlers das wird morgen ein spannender
Tag im Rammstein danke für die
Einordnung nach Berlin Theo Keule
ja welche anderen Länder noch Leopard 2
Panzer haben das und weitere
Hintergründe haben wir in unserer App
zusammengestellt da finden sie auch ein
Video das den Unterschied zwischen
Kampfpanzern und Schützenpanzern erklärt
für Frankreichs Präsident macron ist es
ein Schlüsselprojekt für viele Franzosen
ein Reizthema das heute 100.000 auf die
Straße trieb es geht um die Rentenreform
weil die Bevölkerung immer älter wird
plant die Regierung des Eintrittsalter
von zurzeit 62 auf 64 Jahre zu erhöhen
wer die volle Rente bekommen will muss
statt bisher 42 künftig 43 Jahre
gearbeitet haben aus Paris berichtet
eine Ahrend
Massenproteste in Paris zu Tausenden
ziehen sie durch die Straßen gegen eine
Rentenreform die sie brutal und
ungerecht nennen
in Frankreich haben wir schon seit
vielen Jahren geringe Löhne die
Arbeitsbedingungen werden immer
schlimmer und nun sagt man uns noch wir
sollen zwei Jahre länger arbeiten das
macht uns wütend
und so wird im ganzen Land gestreikt
viele Schulen und Metrostationen bleiben
geschlossen und auch in den Raffinerien
wird die Arbeit eingestellt mehr als
zwei Drittel der Bevölkerung lehnen
macrons große Reform ab die die
Regierung jedoch für unumgänglich hält
das derzeitige System seit zu
kompliziert und vor allem zu teuer in
einer Gesellschaft die immer älter wird
erklärt der Präsident heute von seiner
Dienstreise in Spanien
da ist immer weniger arbeitende und
immer mehr Rentner gibt muss diese
Reform umgesetzt werden um die
Gerechtigkeit zwischen den Generationen
aufrecht zu erhalten nach 2019 ist es
bereits macrons zweiter reformanlauf mit
dem Zugeständnis die Mindestrente auf
1200 € im Monat zu erhöhen scheint er
die Menschen auf der Straße allerdings
nicht zu erreichen
die Wut gegen die Reform eint die sonst
so zersplitterten Gewerkschaften und das
hier heute soll erst der Auftakt sein
aber ob und wie lange die Proteste
Frankreich lahmlegen können hängt doch
davon ab wie schnell die Regierung ihre
Reform durch das Parlament bringen kann
die Debatte ist für Anfang Februar
geplant doch bis dahin sind bereits
weitere Streiks und Demos angekündigt
der Deutsche Bundestag hat die
Gräueltaten des sogenannten islamischen
Staates an den Jesiden als Völkermord
anerkannt und zwar einstimmig 2014
hatten is-kämpfer tausende Jesiden aus
ihrer Heimat im Nordirak vertrieben
versklavt oder ermordet Frauen und
Kinder wurden systematisch misshandelt
und vergewaltigt etwa 200.000 Angehörige
der religiösen Minderheit leben
inzwischen in Deutschland es ist die
größte yezidische Gemeinde außerhalb des
Iraks
die Gewerkschaft Verdi ruft im
Tarifstreit mit der Deutschen Post zu
bundesweiten Warnstreiks auf
Beschäftigte in Brief und paketzzentren
sind seit heute Nachmittag und auch
morgen ganztägig zum Streik aufgerufen
die Gewerkschaft fordert 15% mehr Geld
bei einer Vertragslaufzeit von einem
Jahr
Deutschland wächst die Zuwanderung hat
die Bevölkerungszahl bei uns auf einen
neuen Rekordwert steigen lassen nach
einer ersten Schätzung des Statistischen
Bundesamtes lebten hier Ende vergangenen
Jahres
84,3 Millionen Menschen fast 4 Millionen
mehr als vor zehn Jahren
2022 kamen rund 1,4 Millionen mehr nach
Deutschland als ins Ausland weggezogen
gebremst wurde das Bevölkerungswachstum
durch die sinkende Geburtenrate und die
zunehmende Zahl der Sterbefälle
mit großen Schritten in Richtung
Normalität ab Anfang Februar fallen
nicht nur die maskenpflicht entfernt
Zügen sondern auch Corona Sonderregeln
am Arbeitsplatz das sieht eine
entsprechende Verordnung des
Bundesarbeitsministeriums vor dann
müssen Arbeitgeber nicht mehr prüfen ob
sie zum Schutz gegen eine Infektion
Homeoffice oder Tests anbieten sollten
eine test- oder heimarbeitspflicht gab
es ja sowieso schon seit März nicht mehr
von Normalität nach Corona ist etwa
jeder zehnte genesene weit entfernt
Abgeschlagenheit Muskelschwäche oder
Kurzatmigkeit bleiben also
unterschiedlichste Symptome die unter
long Kurve zusammengefasst werden andere
werden möglicherweise von der Impfung
krank die Betroffenen fühlen sich häufig
allein gelassen und darum heute eine
Protestaktion vor dem Bundestag Susanna
400 Feldbetten mit Portraits viel
erkrankter und diese Aktion vor dem
Reichstag will die Initiative nicht
genesen darauf hinweisen dass sich viele
longkowith Betroffene und mutmaßlich
impfgeschädigten Stich gelassen fühlen
auch Felicia und Stefanie sind gekommen
beide haben kurz nach der kurve-impfung
Schwere Nervenschäden entwickelt ich
kann in meinem Beruf im Moment nicht
arbeiten und ich kann vor allem nicht
richtig laufen ich war vorher
halbmarathonläuferin was noch dazu kommt
ist die soziale echtung es ist ein
Problem was nicht anerkannt wird was
selbst viele Ärzte eigentlich glauben
Erschöpfung Nervenschmerzen
Gefäßerkrankungen häufige Symptome
sowohl von longkowitz-patienten als auch
mutmaßlich impfgeschädigten für die
Erforschung von non-ko wird hat die
Bundesregierung rund 100 Millionen Euro
zugesagt mögliche im Schäden würden
erstmal untersucht
aber selbstverständlich ist der Bund
dann in der Pflicht und wird dann den
Betroffenen auch helfen zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt also ist es noch nicht ganz
klar was genau im Schäden also ausmacht
genau das wird in der Uniklinik Marburg
untersucht hier gibt es eine der wenigen
Spezialambulanzen für mutmaßlich
impfgeschädigte mit eigener Forschung
wenn sie über 6000 Patienten auf der
Warteliste haben können sie nicht mehr
selektieren wir brauchen dringender
unsere Hilfe und wer braucht sie weniger
dringend die Anzahl der Meldungen von
Verdachtsfällen schwerer Nebenwirkungen
liegt nach Zahlen des
Paul-Ehrlich-Instituts bei rund 50.000
Fällen unabhängig von der konkreten Zahl
wünschen sich Betroffene wie Felicia und
Stefanie viel mehr Forschung um nicht
nur long-patienten sondern auch
mutmaßlich impfgeschädigten zu helfen
wegen Corona hat sich China fast drei
Jahre lang abgeschottet jetzt ist die
strikte nullcovit-politik Geschichte und
Millionen Chinesen machen sich auf zum
Neujahrsfest Verwandte besuchen oder
aber endlich wieder Urlaub machen
besonders sehnsüchtig werden sie in
Thailand erwartet wo die wichtigste
Branche des Landes auf einen Neustart
nach Corona angewiesen ist dazu Norman
Odenthal
empfangen wie Popstars die Chinesen sind
da wieder da es gibt Applaus Blumen
kleine Geschenke Thailand öffnet seine
Arme der Gesundheitsminister begrüßt und
klingt wie ein Wirtschaftsminister
wir sollten nicht überschnappen und auch
keine Panik haben das ist unsere Chance
auf wirtschaftliche Erholung nach all
den immensen Verlusten der vergangenen
drei Jahre
vor der Pandemie kamen jedes Jahr 11
Millionen Chinesen nach Thailand 30
Prozent Marktanteil jetzt werden schon
nach nur zwei Wochen 1,8 Millionen
erwartet Nachholbedarf dabei ist die
Virus Sorge sicher nicht verflogen sie
sprühen fleißig dagegen an oder lassen
sich extra noch mal impfen
ich mache mir Sorgen wenn all die
Chinesen jetzt zu uns kommen das ist
schon meine sechste Dosis aber dann bin
ich beruhigter
Urlaub soll entspannen die Gäste aus
China haben das wohl nie mehr empfunden
als jetzt und hier
konnten wir nicht Reisen waren
eingesperrt so lange jetzt endlich lässt
China uns wieder raus viel Spaß eine
gute Zeit
das wünscht er uns er hat sie schon
endlich wieder
seit gut fünf Jahren ist sie
Regierungschefin in Neuseeland jetzt hat
ihr cinderadern überraschend angekündigt
im Februar zurückzutreten sie habe für
den Job nicht mehr genug im Tank sagte
sie den Tränen nach Adam wurde 2017
jüngste Ministerpräsidentin der Welt
machte vieles anders setzte etwa auf
strikte 0,- Politik für ihr Land
International wurde er sensible Reaktion
auf die Terroranschläge von Christchurch
ihre Pläne für die Zukunft mehr Zeit für
die Familie und endlich heiraten
jetzt zum Fußball Norbert und der soll
Tante Käthe also sprich Rudi Völler der
neue Team nicht Teamchef aber der
Sportchef der deutschen
Nationalmannschaft ja und der hat ja dem
DFB schon mal so richtig aus der Patsche
geholfen nämlich sogar tausendwende
damals als Teamchef jetzt soll er nach
dem bio-hoffrücktritt einspringen der
neu gegründete dfb-expertenrad Tag heute
in Frankfurt und will den Gremien diesen
Personalvorschlag unterbreiten Markus
haben beim DFB in Frankfurt wie ist das
einzuschätzen
ja was noch einmal Rudi könnte man sagen
Weltmeister ist halt Spieler geworden
Vize Weltmeister als Teamchef und jetzt
soll Rudi nationale noch einmal
einspringen als Sportdirektor für gut
anderthalb Jahre bis zum Abschluss der
Europameisterschaft in Deutschland 2024
und so wie ich höre nur für die Männer
Nationalmannschaft für die wichtigen
Bereiche Frauen Jugend zukünftige
zukünftige Strukturen soll intern noch
jemand gefunden werden der 62-Jährige
eigentlich schon Rentner nicht die
innovativste und nicht die kreativste
Lösung aber er kann und soll schnell
helfen er soll mit seiner typischen Art
für eine sympathische eine nahbare Art
sorgen und das brauchen der DFB und die
Nationalmannschaft dringend danke nach
Frankfurt danke Markus
ja jetzt ist es perfekt der Wechsel von
gladbachstorhüter Jan Sommer nach
München der 34er Namen heute schon am
bayern-training teil
durch wachsende Auftrag beim Biathlon
Weltcup in Antholz für die deutschen
Athletinnen beim Sprint über 7,5 km
wurde Denise Herrmann Wick nach zwei
Fehlern im Liegen schießen als beste
deutsche Sekte einen Rang dahinter
überraschend Janina hätte ich Waltz
siegerin wurde die Italienerin Dorothea
zu den Australian Open die gute
Nachricht Laura Siegemund hat auch ihr
zweites Spiel gewonnen und ist damit die
letzte deutsche im Einzelwettbewerb denn
und damit zu schlechten Nachricht auch
Olympiasieger Alexander Zverev ist
ausgeschieden
er hatte vor allem mit sich selbst zu
kämpfen nach seiner langen
Verletzungspause war Alexander Zverev
gegen den US-Amerikaner Michael Moore
noch weit entfernt von alter Form es war
nicht genug weil ich halt sieben Monate
Pause hatte aber
was was von meiner Seite halt nicht
genug den ersten Satz entschieds im Tie
Break noch für sich doch dann hatte er
immer größere Mühe machte zu viele
Fehler so ebnete sein zwölfter
Doppelfehler letztlich den Weg zum
Matchball für den US-Amerikaner Mo und
der nutzte ihn gewannen vier Sätzen und
ließ ratlos zurück
ja die letzte deutsche Hoffnung im
Einzel Lauer Siegemund die spielt am
Samstag dann vielen Dank Norbert die
Zeichen stehen bei uns auf Winter gleich
mehr dazu von Katja horneffer der neue
Verteidigungsminister Boris Pistorius im
heute journal Interview mit Marietta
Slomka ab 21 Uhr morgen an meiner Stelle
Barbara Hellweg wir sagen schönen Dank
schönen Abend und auf bald
[Musik]
guten Abend das ansehnliche schneetief
Ingo brachte schon gestern Abend zum
Beispiel Bremervörde Schnee und in den
frühen Morgenstunden begann es dann auch
hier in Nordrhein-Westfalen zu schneiden
dieser Schnee ist weitergezogen nach
Osten inzwischen kommt nicht mehr so
sehr viel aus den Wolken heraus in der
Nacht kann es allerdings durchaus noch
mal für ein Gewitter reichen an der
Nordsee und auf gefährlich glatte
Straßen sollten Sie sich überall gefasst
machen bei Tiefsttemperaturen zwischen
plus 1 Grad in Schleswig-Holstein und
-10 Grad über Schnee am Alpen Rand und
morgen bleibt es zum Teil
dauerfrostliche in Bayern besonders kalt
bleibt es in den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen und am alten Rand bei -3
Grad etwas milder wird es an meinen und
rein mit plus 4 Grad und das wird für
die meisten noch ein freundlicher
Freitag in Schleswig-Holstein gibt's
einige schneeregenschauer und etwas
Schnee fällt auch am Alpenrand am
Nachmittag aber kommt ein neues kleines
Schnee tiefer heran das bringt
wahrscheinlich vor allen Dingen
nordrhein-west und Rheinland-Pfalz
Schnee und dann kommt der Schnee nicht
mehr aus westlichen Richtungen sondern
aus östlichen Richtungen das könnte
besonders in der Nacht zu Sonntag und
Sonntag über Tag kräftig schneiden und
am Montag strahlt dann die Sonne über
dem Neuschnee guten Abend